another surprise Beyonce being a no-show
she was nominated for directing a
lemonade and the Emmy stars were hoping
to catch a glimpse of Queen B some
smells nasty and my name is Beyonce your
be Beyonce's fan it's happening I think
I'm lemon a ting right now our Beyonce
fan had stars and working their own
windblown look but the mere mention of
Queen B I know you looking for yep it
got the Beehive buzzin there was even a
rumor she was going to perform she's on
her way right
so I've heard major Clues were there we
saw her seating card she was on the west
coast outside San Francisco the night
before what are you gonna do you're the
biggest Beyonce fan I don't know and the
Emmy goes to
but the absent mrs. Carter a loss to
Greece Live leaving some let down I was
supposed to be sitting two rows behind
her and she hasn't turned up so this is
nice but this evening is generally has a
sense of loss in there coming any
producers say she was ill and canceled
last minute but late night still hopeful
I want to hear your pitch to get her on
carpool karaoke we were up for an Emmy
against her last week and we want it I
hope that doesn't set us back I'll do
anything she wants
oh come on Beyonce you got to do it